hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to look at a wild way
of studying kanji if you don't know what
kanji are they are IDEO graphic
characters that are used to write words
or parts of words in Japanese they are
originally Chinese but were adopted into
Japanese as well you don't read a kanji
like an alphabet letter but you look at
it as a symbol or a series of symbols
that represent a meaning and if you know
the word that matches that meaning then
you can pronounce the kanji when you
read it of course there's a bit more to
it than that but that's the gist of it
but since they are ideographs and not
pictures kanji usually don't contain
visually concrete images check out this
one
meaning apologize how does that mean
apologize they can be visually complex
containing many different parts and
basic adult literacy and Japanese
requires knowledge of around 2,000 kanji
and literacy and Chinese requires many
more how can you remember how to read
and write thousands of visually complex
characters like this children in Japan
drilled them like crazy from
kindergarten through high school using
simple brute-force rote memorization but
what if you're a gaijin who doesn't want
to spend 12 years learning how to read
kanji there are some strategies we can
use to gain a working knowledge of kanji
in a much shorter amount of time
one method was created by James W heizak
and presented in his book remembering
the kanji let me start with an example
this kanji means elder brother
in other words older brother it has two
components this piece which means mouth
on its own and these two strokes which
kind of look like human legs this gives
us an image of a mean older brother who
never shuts up he's just a big mouth
walking around on two legs saying
annoying mean things
since most kanji consists of various
shapes arranged in different ways heizak
assigns a keyword to each of those
shapes and you can use those keywords to
create a mnemonic story a story or image
that helps you remember the meaning of
that kanji heisig refers to these shapes
or kanji components as primitives as we
can see in this example some primitives
are standalone kanji on their own like
this one meaning mouth while others do
not appear on their own only as a
component of a larger kanji like this
one for human legs and
there's such primitive that only appears
in other country is this one heizak
gives this primitive the keyword devil
you can see that it contains the
character meaning older brother when
this character appears as a primitive in
another kanji we can modify its meaning
slightly to teenager to give us access
to a wider range of images and stories
so this is an image of a teenager with
two horns on his head there are plenty
of adults who think that teenagers are
the devil they look at them and imagine
devil horns on their head I guess that's
because of teenagers evil behavior oh my
gosh why are these teenagers standing in
front of 7-eleven this kanji means
undress it contains the primitive
meaning devil or evil teenager and
another piece which means moon on its
own but you know what - moon is also a
transitive verb meaning to show your
bare butt to someone as a prank so as a
primitive I mean as part of another
country this component can take on the
meaning of flesh or body part those are
the keywords chosen by Isaac but I think
bare butt works too so we know that this
kanji clearly means undressed because it
shows an evil teenager possessed by the
devil stripping down to his bare butt or
her bare butt or insert your pronoun
here bear but by the way just like bear
but evil teenager is my idea and not the
exact keyword given by Isaac when I used
his method I changed some of the key
words in the book - ones that were more
memorable to me he recommends you don't
do that but well I did it you just have
to make sure you're personally chosen
keywords aren't used for other kanji or
primitives this kanji means pointed as
in sharp it contains the primitive
meaning devil or evil teenager same
thing really in this one on the left
meaning metal which also appears on its
own meaning gold the word pointed refers
to those sharp metal objects that evil
teenagers possessed by the devil carry
in their pockets so they can rob all the
innocent adults or even worse
why are some of these kanji stories so
insane or ridiculous look at what I
wrote on the inside cover of my copy of
remembering the kanji do not read these
stories without my permission
many are intentionally disturbing to aid
memorization and yes I realize that my
handwriting here might be just as
disturbing the stories for these kanji
don't always have to be insane or
shocking you just need to imagine a
vivid memorable image this kanji means
storm the bottom component means wind
and the top one means mountain both of
these exist as independent kanji as well
for this kanji I imagined a storm so
powerful that the wind tears a mountain
out of the ground that sends it flying
into the air that's why the mountain is
on top of the wind see as long as you
come up with a vivid image it doesn't
have to be shocking
this right here is a kanji meaning large
but when it appears as a primitive and
other kanji heizak recommends using the
keyword st. Bernard a kind of dog but
that's kind of lame
how's this for an alternative Godzilla
how can you not come up with a memorable
image using Godzilla but I suppose you
could use another large beast like King
Kong or something this kanji means
thinking the bottom component is
Godzilla and the top component means
nose which also appears on its own with
its own story
imagine Godzilla roaming around your
city with his nose in the air sniffing
for the smell of humans to eat people
with stinking body odor are the ones
he'll find first and tear them limb from
limb with his sharp teeth this kanji
means person but when it appears as a
primitive in other kanji you can choose
a specific person who's very memorable
to you when I did the remembering the
kanji course I used a childhood friend
of mine who was always getting into
trouble because I had lots of stories
about him but since you're watching and
you don't know my friend let me choose a
new memorable person right now how about
Arnold Schwarzenegger this kanji means
rest when the person primitive appears
on the left side of a kanji its shape is
slightly modified like it's been
squeezed into a narrower space this
primitive on the right means tree and
also appears on its own as an
independent kanji you might be thinking
okay Arnold Schwarzenegger is sitting
under a tree resting yeah that's fine
but that's kind of lame Arnold
Schwarzenegger has been pulling trees
right out of the ground and chopping
them up into wood with his bare hands
all day so now he needs to rest after
resting for a solid thirty Seconds Arne
stands up again and starts uprooting
more trees feeling well-rested this
kanji means dwell as in to live in a
place this component on the right takes
on the visual keyword of Candlestick
when it's a primitive as a kanji on its
own it means Lord and has its own story
back when he dwelled in Austria Arnold
Schwarzenegger was very poor and dwelled
in a little shack with no electricity
instead he set a three meter tall candle
stick inside the shack
that he could dwell on himself in the
mirror even after dark note that dwell
on has the meaning of focus on so this
is different from the meaning of the
kanji but it's a play on words that can
reinforce my memory of the keyword even
more Isaac's keyword for this primitive
is sau meaning an adult female pig but I
added a second option piglet that is
piglet from the Winnie the Pooh series
it's fine to use both since they're
closely related but piglet might provide
a more vivid image for certain kanji
this kanji means pursue it contains two
primitives sow and rode imagine a swarm
of 50 South escaping from their farm and
running down the road with a desperate
farmer pursuing them trying to get them
back this kanji means drama as in
theatre performance it contains three
primitives tiger piglet and saber but
I'm going to modify Tiger to Tigger to
fit in with piglet and while saber as in
sword is a decent keyword I'm going to
make it light saber
[Music]
in this drama this dramatic play the
climax consists of Tigger and piglet
having a duel with lightsabers it's
supposed to be a mere drama just acting
but Tigger accidentally kills piglet
vivid images are great and some of the
most vivid images for you might be
memories of things you've experienced
this kanji means window it contains four
primitives housed human legs elbow and
heart for this kanji I remember the time
I came home after I'd forgotten my house
key so I had to get inside by climbing
through a tiny window into the kitchen
which we left open for our cat I
imagined the image of my body half
inside the house with my human legs
hanging outside after finally squeezing
through and landing on the kitchen floor
I had a sore elbow and my heart was
racing from all the adrenaline this
really happened to me actually four or
five different times so it's hard for me
to forget memorizing so many kanji using
simple rote memorization would be really
hard or at least take a long time but
using mnemonics using your imagination
and associations to help you remember is
an extremely useful tool in your arsenal
it's also a heck of a lot more
interesting than just drilling the same
kanji a million times in order to
remember it so if you're learning
Japanese Kanji have a look at high zigs
remembering the kanji and give it a try
of course it requires a lot of
dedication to come up with stories for
2,000 different kanji and you do have to
review them in order to reinforce them
but people who complete the program and
do their reviews rarely regret it
there's also a version for Chinese as
well which comes in two versions
simplified chinese and traditional
chinese but even if you don't use this
specific method the general idea of
using your imagination and creativity as
a memory tool is something that we can
learn from it oh and I must apologize
for forgetting to explain this kanji
meaning apologize this one contains two
primitives words and shoot each of which
have their own stories and can be broken
down even further this kanji represents
an abusive husband every time he hurts
his wife he comes back to her and
apologizes profusely but this time when
she hears his words
the question of the day to people who
have used the remembering the kanji
course to learn kanji what was your
experience with it did it help you
remember the meanings of kanji and to
other people do you use any kinds of
memory techniques that help you learn
characters words or other parts of a
language let us know in the comments
down below if you enjoyed this video
then check out liang focus on the
various social media platforms like
YouTube Facebook Instagram and Twitter
and as always I want to say a very
special thanks to all of my patreon
supporters especially these amazing ones
right here on the screen
they are my top tier patreon supporters
thank you very much to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
you